pues un aniversario particular de de
chernóbil de
1986 hoy 26 de abril pues
justamente la visita el director general
de la agencia
nuclear de
la aiea a chernóbil habla de la
preocupación que hay en la comunidad
internacional sobre un accidente que
pudiera darse a partir de la guerra
sabemos del riesgo enorme que hay y
sobre todo porque pudiera perderse la
refrigeración del núcleo esta especie de
vasija de acero donde están los
combustibles usados y el riesgo que se
se pierde está refrigeración implica
para este tipo de centrales desde luego
qué
la visita del director general de la
agencia está acompañada de un grupo de
personas especialistas en seguridad que
estarán proveyendo de el equipo
necesario
a las personas en campo para poder hacer
frente a cualquier eventualidad y pues
no deje de preocuparse en un contexto de
preocupar en un contexto en el cual la
tensión entre rusia y occidente crece y
en el cual occidente está aportando un
mayor armamento pesado a tania mire
efectivamente grossi dijo que se
hicieron las evaluaciones de las
instalaciones y que el paso de tanques y
de artillería por la zona afectó a los
niveles de radiación cuál es el peligro
de que haya un nuevo accidente nuclear y
no sólo en chernóbil sabemos que ucrania
es hogar de varias plantas nucleares e
inclusive la más grande que tiene europa
claro bueno las centrales nucleares
están fuertemente reguladas por los
gobiernos dado el riesgo que éstas
implican tienen importantes
[Música]
extracciones de agua y de vertidos
radiactivos
no solamente al agua sino al aire y si
se dejan de observar las regulaciones
establecidas pues hay un riesgo desde
luego por los productos de fisión y
activación entonces lo que hacen este
tipo de regulaciones de los gobiernos es
justamente
medir los niveles en los cuales se puede
invertir estos recibos al agua o al aire
al momento de no ser observados como
como debe de ser pues desde luego
aumentan los riesgos en el momento en el
que el ejército ruso ha estado presente
en territorio ucraniano ya por más de
dos meses y en el cual durante fases de
este conflicto ha tomado algunas de las
instalaciones nucleares pues desde luego
esto preocupa